hey everyone welcome back to another
video by simply learn
in this video session we'll be
discussing about some of the best
laptops for coding
we will discuss various laptops the
features specifications etc in different
price ranges
but before we begin with the laptops
there are some factors that we need to
take care of before buying a laptop for
coding
so now let's discuss the things to keep
in mind while buying a laptop for coding
choosing the finest laptops for
programming is more complicated than
simply purchasing the most expensive
machine available
it must include the necessary components
to assist you in your coding and
programming responsibilities
if you're a programmer you'll
undoubtedly spend hours staring at a
laptop
so you should get one with a good
display and there are many other similar
factors that you should consider
so now here we'll go over several
considerations to make while purchasing
a laptop for code
let's start with the first one which is
ram
ram is one of the most crucial
components in determining the
performance of your machine
it enables your computer to execute many
necessary functions such as loading apps
browsing the internet creating a
spreadsheet and so on the minimum advice
spam for a laptop for programming or
office work is 8gb
this amount will barely get you through
and if you have the money you should
always go with the 16gb option or above
the next thing you should keep in mind
while buying a laptop for coding is
storage
if you want your computer to run swiftly
be sure it has an ssd
this will help your laptop to be fast
and work quickly regardless of the task
ssds make everything faster including
booting up the operating system
compiling code running programs loading
projects and many other things
next up we have the processor
while buying a laptop for coding the
number of cores frequency and thermal
design power are all important
considerations
the minimum processor requirement which
is the single core i5 processor is
sufficient for running simple linear
codes but if you are into advanced
coding and need to run numerous codes at
once a high-end processor like an i7 but
an i9 is recommended
next we have the battery life
the long-lasting battery is necessary if
you're planning to buy a laptop
recording but you will be constantly
working on the laptop for six to eight
hours
next is keyboard it is up to you to
select a keyboard and any keyboard with
an unusual layout such as these in
different places and sizes can cause
problems for you especially because you
will be using it for coding
as a result make a decision about
compactness and low light situations
so there are some of the things that you
must consider while buying a laptop
recording
let's move on and have a look at some of
the laptops that are well suited for
floating
also we have categorized all these
laptops with different price ranges so
that it's easy for you to choose which
one is best for you
so first we'll have a look at some of
the best laptops for coding under rupees
30 000
so here we have three laptops
the first is hp envy 255 g8
this hp laptop has amd ryzen 3 4 cores
8gb ram ddr4
it has a storage capacity of one
terabyte and integrated amd radeon
graphics
it has a display of 15.6 inches and has
windows 11 operating system
the current price of hp nv255 g8 laptop
is rupees 29 390.
the second laptop in this segment is the
lenovo v14 igl
it has the intel celeron n4020
two cores 4gb ram ddr4 and with a
storage capacity of 256gb along with an
integrated graphic card
it has a display of 14 inches with an
anti-glare screen and also has a windows
11 home operating system
the current price of the lenovo v14 igl
laptop is rupees 24999
the third laptop would be the lenovo
ideapad 110
this laptop is a fine example of good
performance and affordability
it has an amd quad core a6 processor 4gb
ram ddr3 and storage capacity of 500 gb
along with an amd radeon r4 graphic card
the lenovo ideapad 1.0 has a screen size
of 15.6 inches with hd led backlit pn
glare slim display and a windows 10 home
operating system
the price of this lenovo ideapad is
rupees 26500
all of these laptops work fine for entry
level and development purposes
now let's have a look at the best laptop
for coding under rupees 40 000
so here we have two laptops that are
suited perfectly for coding rated tasks
first is the hp 15 1 5s
this hp laptop has 11 gen intel core i3
processor 2 cores
it has ram of 8gb ddr4 and a storage
capacity of 512gb
this laptop has integrated intel uhd
graphics
the hp 1515s has a screen size of 15.6
inches with fhd ips anti-flare
it also has wled backlit display and
pre-loaded windows 10 home with lifetime
validity and a free upgrade to windows
11.
let's discuss about the price of this
the current price of the hv15s is rupees
41990
it is a bit higher than 40 000 limit but
we can consider this laptop in this
switch
the second laptop for coding under
rupees 40 000 with the dell inspiron
3505
it has an amd ryzen 3 processor
2 cores a ram of 8 gb ddr4 and a storage
capacity of 1 terabyte
it also has an amd radio on vega 3
graphics
the stell laptop has a screen size of
15.6 inches with an anti-clear led
backlit display and has pre-loaded
windows 10 home with microsoft office
home and student 2019 lifetime validity
the current price of dell inspiron 3505
is rupees 38 445 which is a reasonable
price for this kind of laptop
now let's take a look at some of the
best laptops for coding below rupees 50
000
so here we have the lenovo ideapad 3 and
msi modem 14.
first let's have a look at the lenovo
ideapad 3.
it comes with amd ryzen 5 hexa core
processor
ram of 8gb ddr4 and a storage capacity
of 512 gb
the lenovo laptop has a screen sensor
15.6 inches with a full hd anti-glare
display and windows 11 phone with
microsoft office home and student 2021
now let's discuss the price of this
laptop
lenovo ideapad 3 laptops current price
is rupees 45 990.
coming to our next laptop is msi model
14.
this msi laptop comes with an intel i5
10 gen processor
it has a ram of 8 gb ddr4 and a storage
capacity of 512 gigabyte
it also comes with intel uhd graphics
the laptop has a screen size of 14
inches with a full hd display and
pre-loaded windows 10 phone which is
upgradable to windows 11.
the current price of msi modern 14 is
rupees 42 990 which is a reasonable
price for this kind of laptop
now moving on to the next laptops for 14
which are under the 70 000.
here we have the hp pavilion 14 with amd
ryzen 5 with 6 cores
this hp laptop has a ram of 16 gb ddr4
and a storage capacity of 500 gigabyte
and comes with amd radeon graphics card
the laptop has a screen size of 14
inches with a full hd display
it has windows 10 the free upgrade to
windows 11 and contains microsoft office
phone and student 2019
hp pavilion 14 current price is rupees
62 240.
now the second laptop is the acer s2f3
with an entry core i5 processor
it has ram of 8gb and a storage capacity
of 512gb and it comes with an integrated
graphics
the laptop has a screen size of 14
inches with a full hd ips non-glass
display
it has windows 10 home and its battery
life is intelligently optimized to last
in everyday program
the current price of asus swift 3 is
rupees 64 250.
now moving on to the best laptops for
coating under rupees 90 000.
so under 90 000 we have two laptops that
are well suited for food
the first is the lenovo ideapad 75 pro
in this lenovo laptop we have the 5th
gen amd ryzen 7 with 8 cores
the ram of this laptop is 16 gb the
storage capacity is 500 per gigabyte
while having integrated amd radeon
graphics
laptop has a screen size of 14 inches
with the qhd display anti-glare
it has pre-loaded windows 11 with
lifetime validity and this ideapad
liberates you from your power outlet
thanks to its nearly all day battery
life
lenovo ideapad slim 5 pro current price
is rupees
000
now coming on to the next laptop is the
lenovo thinkpad x1
in this lenovo laptop we have an intel
core i3 processor
the ram of this laptop is 16 gb and the
storage capacity is 512gb which is quite
low at the price of this laptop this
laptop has a screen size of 15.6 inches
with a full hd and tdi display and has
windows 104 which comes with integrated
graphics as well
the current price of the lenovo thinkpad
x140
moving on to the best laptops under one
lakh 25 000
so here first we have the apple macbook
air 2020.
[Music]
in this mac we have the apple m1 chip
with eight cores
the ram of this mac is 8 gb the storage
capacity is up to 2 terabytes
it comes with the apple 7 core gpu
graphics
the mac as a screen has a 13.3 inches
and an led backlight display with ips
technology
it has a stunning retina display and
images come alive with new levels of
realism the text is sharp and clear and
the colors are more vibrant
the current price of the apple macbook
air 2020 is rupees 1 17 900.
then we have the hp spectre x360
this laptop has an 11 gen intel core i5
processor with 4 cores the ram of this
laptop is 32gb and the storage capacity
is 512gb of ssd
plus 32gb intel obtained memory
also it has intel integrated graphics
card while also containing a touch
screen feature
this hp laptop has a screen size of 13.3
inches full hd screen multi-touch
enabled ips edge to edge glass
the operating system of this laptop is
windows 10 phone the price for the hp
spectre x360 is rupees 91150
so here are some of the best laptops for
coding in different price ranges that
you can consider while buying a laptop
for coding programming and similar tasks
all of these laptops are feature loaded
and have the specification that are
necessary for coding all the related
tasks
alright guys with that we have come to
the end of this video session
if you like this video please give it a
thumbs up i hope it really helped you
all thanks for watching stay safe and
keep learning
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn youtube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos turn it up and get certified
click here